it's time for the launching Chronister a
television journal of the important
issues of the hour brought show you
every Monday Wednesday and Friday a
presentation of the lawn gene which nor
wats company maker of launching the
world's most honored watch and wit nor
distinguished companion to the world
honored lon gene good evening this is
frank night may I introduce our
co-editors for this edition of the lawn
gene chrome scope mister william
bradford huie editor of the american
mercury and mr. henry hazlitt
contributing editor of newsweek magazine
our distinguished guest for this evening
is mr. henry h fowler administrator of
the defense production Administration
and the National production authority
the opinions expressed are necessarily
those of the speakers mr. Fowler you are
the man who is responsible chiefly
responsible for our defense production
how much or net balance did the steel
strike set us back the only real
estimate one can give is in terms of the
actual tonnage of Steel lost mr. Hazzard
and that is approximately 20 million
tons of steel which we can never recover
because that it has been lost beyond
recall now to give you some picture of
what that means that would be roughly
equivalent to the total production of
Great Britain for an entire year well is
there any chance of our getting again
into another strike situation well I
certainly hope not but in this game
anything can happen and usually does
have you any estimates on the prospects
of a coal strike for example no I'm
afraid I do not but I do not believe
that at this particular time the war
economy or the defense economy could
afford anything like the
we love softly well they've been some
apparently conflicting estimates of how
much the steel strike set us back or how
much we're recovering I think you made a
statement saying that we had a
remarkable start the steel companies
made a remarkable start and getting back
into production but i think mr. Steelman
made a statement saying that some items
might still be delayed even a year from
now now are those two statements
reconcilable they are because the steel
industry has made a remarkable start in
getting back towards what we call
capacity operation for example this past
week they were up to eighty five percent
of what would be capacity operation
however the brakes and the pipelines in
the flow of various forms and shapes of
Steel various parts and components made
of steel that ultimately may have their
impact upon the production of some item
may show up anytime the near future
stretching on out into the next four or
five months mr. feller what percentage
of our steel production is now going
into arms the estimates vary but usually
we believe that about ten percent goes
into direct military production and
perhaps an additional five percent goes
into indirect military production in
what we call the components and parts or
be prone to those percentages who have
to go through and copper and aluminum
and all their varying for depending upon
the particular material estimates of
ronas highs around forty percent for
aluminum and around thirty five percent
for copper well now in this vast
production program with our is a
rearmament program what is that costing
the average American family what's it
taking away from us well I can only give
you that in terms of national dollar
totals there have been appropriated up
to date for the military production and
Sherman construction programs a total of
approximately a hundred and twenty eight
billion dollars in the last three years
well now how does that affect the
average American family what does the
average family listening to this program
tonight have to give up his result of
that rearmament effort well I think the
main thing that the average American
family has had to give up and we'll have
to give up under this program is the tax
dollar the family today has not been
deprived of any of the essentials and a
very few of the luxuries due to the fact
that the economy has been so strong so
so rich and full of expensive in
developing new supplies of these
critical materials nobody has had to
give up or not get an automobile or
television set or a refrigerator because
of this this rearmament learn a lot of
the red question another way how much
has the automobile production been cut
back let's say how much it is being cut
back this quarter as compared with a pre
defense program well at the very at the
very lowest level of permitted
production the automobile industry for
about two quarters was down to fifty
percent of what had been its peak
production in 1950 was that as much as
it was permitted to make sure but even
at that level there was no great demand
for cars because the demand that's also
falling off is that what it sold you
might have to wait a few weeks or
perhaps even a month for a particular
model during some of this period but
there was no shortage of passenger
automobile and is there any consumers
item that is in short supply as a result
of your cutbacks that you know of we
keep a fairly constant check through the
various distributive outlets throughout
the country and we find that each
quarter there will be threatened
shortages of maybe a half a dozen
consumer items in the following four
will beef up as we call it the Alec
nations of materials that go to that
particular class of producers and buy a
little bit of manipulation of supply and
that the way we tended to avoid it avoid
any serious consumer shortages over a
long period how do you mean sure that
our country is so rich and has such a
high rate of productivity that our
people can enjoy guns and butter and
electric refrigerators and television
sets there's no no sacrifice necessary
on the part of the American people we
can arm the free world and still have
everything we are accustomed to having
in our way of life in terms of our
material and productive resources i
think i would agree substantially with
that statement i would want to qualify
it in one respect that in a time such as
we have been through it has been
necessary to hold off for example
various types of construction activity
in our desire to give the right away and
to put first the new type of industrial
development what about whom sir has
anybody been denied a new home because
of the rearmament program the rate of
construction of homes has been on a
relatively high level all during this
period there have been conservation
practices in the types of copper
materials that are used in a home the
number of pounds the number of uses but
the number of units housing units as
such has not been substantially curved
but I should say on both of your
questions however in order to be rounded
out that there were credit restrictions
imposed not by the NPA or DPA would buy
other parts of the government apparatus
that may have artificially constricted
consumer demand during this period for
many of these looking it's a question
the other way what have been the
objectives of the defense program of the
positive defense program and how far
along have you gotten now have we gotten
now and reaching those objectives well
have been for basic objectives from the
begin
one might say that those objectives were
the objectives of the Congress in
passing the defense production act and
they've been held to firm in they are
these number one increase very
substantially beef production of new
military weapons and end products to
adequately armed our forces in career at
home and at the verse other points on
the periphery and to provide a military
shield behind which we might affect
total mobilization if total war should
come objective number two has been to
build a military mobilization base or
the standby capacity or planes that will
enable us to very rapidly increase the
production of planes and tanks and guns
beyond the levels the minimum levels
that are necessary for the current
period thirdly to expand the capacity of
our basic resources steel copper
aluminum electric power transportation
and finally to do all three of these
things in such a manner as not to
substantially damaged or impaired
fundamentally the civilian economy well
on an overall basis how far along are we
in reaching those objectives well we're
about half through either in terms of
time or in terms of the quantity of
military and products that have been
delivered or in production the amount of
the industrial expansion the amount of
the standby facilities American public
has gotten an impression I'm very much
afraid that we're further along than we
are because we have managed to lick some
of the most difficult material shortages
and the mobilization effort hasn't hurt
no it doesn't mean we're through mr.
Fowler I'm sure that every member of our
audience must would like to have an
answer to this question suppose after we
expand our facilities as we as you plan
to expand them and we are increase our
production
to this point that you envision and then
we don't have any war what will happen
to us well the answer that I think I
should make to that question is that in
that event I would want to be around in
charge but i will give one further
answer i think that with the resources
and facilities that will be available
the dynamic system of American
competitive enterprise will be
confronted by the greatest challenge to
do what I believe it can do is to
greatly enrich the standard of living of
America and and perhaps or the courts
the world well thank you very much for
being with us tonight sir the editorial
board for this edition of the Long gene
Kranz cope was mister william bradford
huie and mr. henry hazlitt our
distinguished guest was mr. Henry H
Fowler administrator of the defense
production Administration and the
National production authority